do you worry about nuclear war in the
21st century
how do we avoid it
anyone who doesn't worry about nuclear
war
doesn't have a gray cell functioning
of course everyone is worried about
nuclear wars or friday
it's very easy to see how
steps could be taken they've even been
recommended that would lead to nuclear
war
so you can read
articles even by
liberal commentators who say we should
uh drop all the pretenses just go to war
against russia they have to be destroyed
uh
you can see proposals coming from
congress
the other leading figures
saying we should establish a no-fly zone
pentagon
objects they point out correctly
that to establish a no-fly zone
you have to
have control of the air
which means
destroying
russian
air defense systems which happen to be
inside russia
we don't know that russia
won't react
even the coal
now almost universal
to ensure that ukraine wins drives out
all the russians
drives them out of the country
sounds nice on paper
but notice the assumption
the assumption is that
vladimir putin this
madman who
just seeks power and is out of control
will sit there quietly
accept defeat
slink away
not use
the
military means that of course he has to
destroy ukraine
one of the interesting comments that
came out in
today's
long
article i think washington post
reviewing
a lot of leaks from
actually
not leaks actually presented by us
intelligence and u.s leaders about the
long build-up to the war but one of the
points that made was
surprised on the part of
british and u.s leaders
about putin's strategy
and his failure
to adopt to fight the war the way the
u.s and britain would
with real
shock and awe destruction of
communication
facilities of
energy facilities and so on they can't
understand why he hasn't done all that
well
could
if you want to
make it very likely that that'll happen
then insist on
fighting until
somehow russia faces total defeat
then
it's a gamble you know but if he's just
crazy and insane as you claim presumably
will use weapons that he hasn't used yet
to
destroy ukraine
so the west is taking
an extraordinary gamble
with the fate of ukraine
gambling
that the madman lunatic
mad vlad
won't use the weapons he has to destroy
ukraine
and
set the stage for escalation up the
ladder which might lead to nuclear war
it's quite a gamble
you